j was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen video in amerika gegen hat
einige youtube-videos viral sag ich mal
in denen es um lost cargo geht das heißt
also sowas wie fracht ware die verloren
gegangen ist wo auch immer auf dem
containerschiff auf dem lkw deren
container geladen hat also wirklich
fette waren die nicht zustellbare oder
verloren gegangen sind dem fairplay ist
dann immer dieses containerschiff sowie
bei mir auch nach vielleicht waren die
wirklich auf diesen container schiff
werde auf jeden fall finde ich es mir ja
scheiße dass ich hier in deutschland
wohne und die waren die diebe stellen
nicht ganz bestellen kann also das ist
echt ein bisschen doof würde ich gerne
in amerika gibt es seiten die
liquidation dot com mit spox.com und
noch irgend so ein bus da kannst du
nicht wirklich auf solche ware bieten
und dir das dann nach hause schicken
lassen und da sind echt manchmal coole
angebote was ich sehr schade finde diese
seite oder anbieter verschiffen nicht
nach deutschland also du kannst da aus
deutschland quasi bieten aber die wahre
wirst du niemals bekommen der versand
geht halt leider nur irgendwelche
us-bundesstaaten ich hatte mal gegoogelt
und wenn auch wie stock da kommt
gestoßen das ist zwar auch eine us seite
aber die verschiebung wonach deutschland
also der konstrukteur mini auswählen und
dann wurden ein bisschen was angezeigt
und da habe ich für 200 euro mal was
verboten und das ist angekommen und
darum geht es heute also ich bin
glücklich dass ich auch verlorene
fruchtbare zu mir nach deutschland in
mein büro bestellen konnte let's go
bevor wir starten muss ich euch aber
noch etwas cooles vorstellen und zwar
habe mir meine freunde von eco wächst
den neuen kodex die bot x1 zukommen
lassen ultra geil ein hochpreisiger
roboter aber was er drauf hat check das
mal aus leute ich bin gerade in meiner
wohnung und schaut da hinten in der ecke
der große kasten wirklichen mörder gerät
ich habe gerade mal ausgepackt hier
haben wir den ex die bot x1 only ich
konnte den neuen sockel oder von lkws
ist schon zwei drei tage testen und ich
muss sagen wirklich geisteskrank das ist
der x1 auch nie von der reihe gibt es
auch noch dem x1 turbo und den x1 plus
die sind ein bisschen günstiger man muss
hier wirklich sagen das ist schon so der
porsche unter den saugroboter und der
ist wirklich krass hat aber mit 1499
euro natürlich auch seinen preis also
wenn ihr nicht so viel geld ausgeben
wollte gewechselt und auch ganz ganz
viele andere coole sau roboter die
deutlich günstiger sind wir haben hier
allerdings ein komplettpaket dh der
saugt und ist gleichzeitig der x1 und
mini brilliert also durch
vollautomatisches saugen und wischen hat
eine unübertroffene navigation eine
objekt vermeidung vom anderen stern und
einen sprachassistenten der immer mit
euch reden ich habe auch schon die
vollautomatische und multifunktionale
station des djs angezeigt und die
erledigt alles für euch sie entleert
schmutz die tauscht das wasser aus sie
trocknet die wäsche ob sie auch sehr
hartnäckigen schmutz entfernen können
sämtliche gegenstände in eurer wohnung
werden erkannt und umfahren und was auch
sehr geiles kabel und so weiter und so
fort verfangen sich nicht so schnell wie
bei anderen saugroboter den borsten ja
ich habe jetzt quasi ein neues haustier
mit hundehütte witzig kriegs 1 befindet
sich ja gerade in meiner wohnung ich bin
jetzt hier im büro eröffnen einfach mal
die aquaworx app dann könnt ihr hier
direkt sehen die räume wurden alle schon
eingezeichnet man kann denn von hier aus
steuern und ich kann vorher noch alles
überwachen familienmitglieder anschauen
so sieht es jetzt aus wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel hund oder ein kleinkind zur
seite könnte ich nach schon und sogar
mit ihm sprechen macht den computer aus
tempeln ich mache jetzt ja auch schon
länger kooperation mit eco wechseln muss
sagen es kommt immer neue features
funktion hinzu das ist echt komisch
anzusehen deswegen jack ma lin x1 ab ok
nico
beginne mit der reinigung aber
sonst sitzt du anfangen oder
leute weiter geht's mit dem video leute
wir sind wieder zurück ich hoffe ihr
seid noch dran auf jeden fall muss ich
kurz sagen das video so wie es
ursprünglich geplant war findet ihr ja
jetzt auf meinem zweiten kanal weil die
sachen die da drin waren waren fall
nicht scheiße also wirklich es hat man
das heißt scheiße ich habe mich auf
jeden fall sehr aufgeregt und ich war
damit nicht zufrieden also wenn ihr
trotzdem sehen wollt was da so drin war
dann checkt auf jeden fall meinen zwei
kanada findet ihr alles das war halt
alles sehr spontan ich habe nicht viel
recherchiert habe direkt das erstbeste
genommen was nicht zu teuer war und ja
ergebnis selber schuld leute hier noch
mal kurz für euch wir sind auf beastoch
hier gibt es wirklich alles alles
mögliche viel ist wohl amazon war es
gibt aber auch andere anbieter die hier
ihre waren anbieten behandelt wird
eigentlich alles von a bis z wie
hannovers tag waren wir haben nicht
zustellbare waren wir haben wahre die
einfach verloren gegangen ist alles
alles mögliche was man sich nur
vorstellen kann ich bin hier gerade auf
der usb stick seite gibt es echt richtig
geile sachen leider kommt für uns nur
die europe seite in betracht wie stoxx
europe wo man zum beispiel solche sachen
ersteigerten ich würde echt gern mit
gehen schaut mal 71.000 euro retail und
wir sind gerade mal bei 1200 euro also
ich hab ich allerdings erst mal iphone
verboten ich glaube acht stück für
insgesamt 510 euro plus versandkosten
und die sind da die machen wir jetzt mal
auf und schauen ob sich das lohnt und ob
man eventuell auch wirklich mal hier
noch dicker einkaufen kann weil meine
die bestellung war halt definitiven flop
letzte okay leute dann würde ich sagen
wollen wir mal ich bin echt mal gespannt
ob sich das lohnt weil 510 euro plus
versand wenn die manchmal 15 19 oder
waren sogar 610 ich habe es doch gerade
nachgeguckt herbst gehört eins von
beiden ich glaube 510 schauen wir
einfach mal ob ich damit bloß machen
kann also ja
und leute ich weiß er schreibt ihr immer
in die kommentare alex verlost immer
wieder war es vielleicht kann ich heute
mal wieder ein iphone verlosen aber nur
wenn es gut wird sonst auch darum geht
es ja nicht hier haben wir hier war
einmal die richtung auch sehr nett kommt
auf jeden fall aus deutschland 510 euro
plus 12 euro versandt die ganz schön
teuer also zwölf euro für sein paket
naja ich weiß nicht ich fange jetzt
einfach mal an wir checken dem zustand
ab und dann werde ich die nach und nach
laden damit ich sehen kann ob die alle
funktionieren so wie ich es gerne hätte
aber er verpackt wir starten hier mit
dem erst das sieht auf den ersten blick
schon mal nicht schlecht aus wir haben
hier ein iphone es ist ein iphone 600
iphone 8 das hier müsste in iphone 8
sein und dann haben wir das einmal in
weiß und wir haben noch ein iphone 8 in
schwarz und ich muss sagen sollte der
zustand von den dingern ist geil also
das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht dass
sie so gut aussehen ich bin zwar immer
ein aber beide zusammen okay hier sind
bei dem schwarzen sind ein paar kratzer
darauf bei dem weißen kaum eigentlich
gar nichts heftig ich weiß nicht genau
wie viel gigabyte das sind aber die
kosten ja so irgendwas zwischen 240 und
320 euro würde ich mal schätzen aktuell
ich habe die preise natürlich nicht im
kopf iphone 8 ist jetzt auch nicht mehr
das neueste modell aber wenn ich die
beide verkauf und die reibungslos
funktionieren dann gehe ich hier
eigentlich safe mit überaus das ist
schon mal gut so machen wir weiter next
idms das ist jetzt ein gerät drei und
vier von acht wir haben hier einmal ja
leider ein zerstörtes komplett zerstört
hinten zumindest und vorne auf also hier
muss man einmal das backcover
austauschen und das display natürlich
auch langes angeht ist halt schwierig
habe keine ahnung also wahrscheinlich
wird man dafür nicht mehr so viel
bekommen das ist jetzt ein iphone ich
kann mir absolut los ist es nicht finden
iphone 6 und was ist der unterschied
zwischen dem iphone 6 und dem iphone 8
optisch war kurz das hier ist gar kein
oder doch es ist ein iphone 8
oder ist das hier ich dachte ich auch
ein bisschen gegen komplett durch aber
nein ist nicht so tschuldigung leute
lasst euch nicht von mir verbinden ich
bin kein iphone experte das tut mir leid
ersparen leute das nächste was ich da
ersteigern werde werden keine iphones
seien aber ein gerät haben wir noch das
ist ebenfalls destroyed hier haben wir
ein absolut demoliertes iphone iks ist
es einfach nix oder dem iphone xl1 von
glaube iphone ickx und iphone xr ich
hoffe beide gehen noch an aber an sich
stand er jetzt nirgendwo das einst von
den länger nicht funktioniert wobei 510
euro bis jetzt ein sehr sehr guter preis
ist sehr sehr gut nach preis würde ich
sagen weil wir aber noch vier geräte so
weiter geht es mit dem nächsten gerät
das sieht eigentlich wieder ganz stabil
aus es ist ein iphone 8 plus würde ich
mal sagen das habe ich hier bei dem
gerade gar nicht gesagt aber hier haben
wir zwei iphone 8 plus und das girlie
iphone sage ich das einfach mal weil das
hier so pink akzente hat wobei dann muss
man aufpassen heutzutage mit seinen
magnetisch hier drin wird heißt man
neben schutz also ich denke man kann es
forlans auto pappen sieht echt gut aus
so dann haben wir hier das nächste
iphone und jetzt ich mache jetzt einfach
zu ende und dann versuche ich die alle
an zu machen okay sonst ich versuche mal
vielleicht geht ja einst an
aber das ist ja doof also die liegen
wahrscheinlich alles schon ziemlich
lange herum geht kein sun
online 1 geht an aber das hier nicht na
ja also ich klemme aber warte mal ich
habe hier gemeinsam laden ich klemme
dieses dort nächste hier als müsst ihr
jetzt hier madeisky bitte bitte bitte
bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte mit
ok das lädt schon mal also es kann
zumindest laden hier sind wir auch schon
drin direkt in dem wunderbar bitte bitte
bitte bitte er ist es wirklich es
entscheide ist der unterschied ist grat
zwischen an und aus es ist ja
let's go ja wolle vielen dank dafür geht
auch an ok das heißt also ich wollte mal
sagen wenn es nicht angeht dann habe ich
quasi direkt 100 euro verloren so
gesehen ok bitte bitte bitte leute an
zeigt mir irgendwas ach ja es geht auch
um meinen körper wenn das jetzt an geht
das ist ein einfacher mann muss das hier
komplett neue austauschen aber ich habe
ja schon hin und wieder mal so geht auch
ein metzger altertum ich habe ja schon
mal hin und wieder so iphone unlock
sings gemacht bis jetzt war es nico ich
bin sehr gerne hier mal die videos ein
also eigentlich hab ich glaube ich immer
verlust gemacht soweit ich das richtig
in erinnerung habe es war auf jeden fall
nie so gut wie jetzt sagen wir mal so
ich musste schon mal start mit laden es
geht alle an bis auf dieses hier da tut
sich gar nichts leider das habe ich
jetzt schon ewig daran gehabt aber ist
nicht schlimm es ist trotzdem sehr sehr
gut weil passt mal auf ich hier haben
wir das dritte iphone 8 plus mit keine
armee für gigabit aber davon haben wir
einfach jetzt schon drei beziehungsweise
zwei weil einzig angeht und sagte ortega
was ist das überhaupt für eine
verpackung eigentlich bin ich die ganze
zeit davon ausgegangen dass hier acht
geräte haben wir haben nur sieben aber
ich mich darüber aufregen soll weiß ich
nicht weil hier haben wir ein fucking
iphone iks in gutem zustand des displays
ein bisschen von kost aber sonst das
waren jetzt letzten aber wenn die beide
auch noch angehen dann war das
eigentlich der deal meines lebens
derjenige der diese versteigerung
gemacht hat hat sich wahrscheinlich
gedacht du scheißt aber ich glaube ich
habe ihm ein einsatz von 510 euro fast
mehr als verdoppelt ich mache jetzt
einfach mal beide an vielleicht gehen
die an wahrscheinlich nicht eins
vielleicht kann man gehen beide nicht an
das heißt wir müssen die an strom
klemmen er wenn das hier jetzt geht ohne
wirtsleute ich könnte hier 1000 euro
rausholen iphone 8 plus da tut sich nix
ja okay doch es geht an moment es ist
wieder außen ein okay ich habe
vielleicht habe ich mich aus zu früh
gefreut weil wenn die jetzt beide nicht
gehen dann haben wir ein problem ja
das tier kostet auf jeden fall noch ich
habe eben gesagt bei dem iphone 840 euro
das war falsch für die normalen achter
bekomme ich 180 euro vielleicht wenn es
gut durch realistisch er 160 ich jetzt
alles ab und dann sehen wir uns gleich
noch mal wieder leute ja leute ich muss
sagen ich bin wirklich glücklich alle
iphones funktionieren bis auf das eine
achter da was redest reuters ich hab's
mal ungefähr im kopf geschlagen was das
ganze denn so wert ist wir haben zwei
normale iphone als ein schwarzes anderen
weiß dass schwarze würde ich mit 160
euro bepreisen das weiß ich mit 180 840
euro dann haben wir drei weitere iphone
8 plus wovon allerdings nur zwei
funktionieren einzelnen graue einzelnen
ping das graue war es meine ich fast nur
16 gigabyte hat würde ich mit 200 euro
ansetzen und das andere in pink mit 64
gbyte für 220 dann noch ein iphone xt
270 was auch funktioniert und ein
zerstörtes iphone nix was auch angeht
200 euro also wenn ich repariere lassen
würde danach verkaufen würde würde ich
100 euro vielleicht noch dann verdienen
kommen wir insgesamt auf 1.120 euro also
610 euro oder sagen mal ungefähr 600
euro gewinnen wenn ich das alles
loswerden das ist schon sehr wild jetzt
habe ich das video schon zu ende gedreht
und ich habe am anfang auch hier die
verlosung angesetzt wenn es geil wir
leute hier das iphone achter hier in
schwarz das hab ich jetzt raus könnte
haben statt einfach anwenden kommentar
und vergesst nicht und instagram namen
dazu zu schreiben damit ich euch
kontaktieren kann die gewinnchance ist
sehr klein dass du gewinnst aber naja
einer wird's halt bekommen am ende mal
schauen wer hätte